Lo que he dibujado aquí en amarillo es una
línea, digamos que sabemos dos cosas de esta línea.
Sabemos que tiene una pendiente "m" y sabemos
también que el punto "a", "b", está en esta línea.
Por lo que la pregunta que trataremos de resolver es,
¿podemos fácilmente obtener una ecuación
para esta línea utilizando esta información?
Así que vamos a intentarlo.
Todo punto en esta línea o todo "x", "y"
en esta línea, tiene que satisfacer la condición
de que la pendiente entre ese punto y digamos
que éste es un punto "x", "y",
es un punto arbitrario en la línea.
El hecho de que esté en la línea, nos dice
que la pendiente entre "a", "b" y "x", "y",
debe de ser igual a "m".
Así que, utilicemos ese conocimiento para
hacer una ecuación.
Entonces,
¿cuál es la pendiente entre "a", "b" y "x", "y"?
Nuestro cambio en "y" y recuerda que la pendiente
es solo el cambio en "y" entre el cambio en "x".
Déjame escribir eso.
La...
pendiente...
es igual...
al cambio...
en "y"...
entre...
el cambio...
en "x"...
Este pequeño triángulo es la letra griega
delta, símbolo para el cambio.
Nuestro cambio en "y", veamos,
si empezamos en "y" igual a...
estamos empezando en "y" es igual a "b" y
si acabamos en "y" igual a esta "y" arbitraria
de aquí, ese cambio en "y" de aquí va ser,
"y" menos "b"...
"y" menos mi "b"...
y eso va a estar sobre nuestro cambio en "x".
Y utilizando la misma lógica, empezamos en "x" igual a "a" y terminamos en "x" igual a esta "x"arbitraria,
sea cual sea la "x" en donde estemos.
Por lo que nuestro cambio en "x" va a ser
este punto final, menos nuestro punto inicial,
menos "a".
Y sabemos que ésta es la pendiente entre
estos dos puntos,
esa es la pendiente entre cualesquiera dos puntos en esta línea y eso va a ser igual a "m".
Entonces esto va a ser igual a "m".
Lo que hemos hecho aquí... lo que hemos hecho
aquí, es crear una ecuación que describe esta línea.
Puede que esté en una forma en la que no
estén acostumbrados a ver,
pero está en una ecuación que describe toda "x" y "y"
que satisfaga esta ecuación estará en esta línea,
porque toda "x" y "y"que satisfaga
esto, la pendiente entre esta "x", "y"
y este punto de aquí, entre
el punto "a", "b", va a ser igual a "m".
Así que vamos de hecho, ahora a convertir esto esto en formas que podamos reconocer más fácil...
por lo que déjame pegar esto.
Para simplificar esta expresión un poco o
por lo menos para deshacernos de este "x"
menos "a" en el denominador, multipliquemos
ambos lados por "x" menos "a",  entonces si
multiplicamos ambos lados por "x" menos "a",
"x" menos "a" en el lado izquierdo de la ecuación,
"x" menos "a" en la izquierda y "x" menos
"a" en la derecha..."x" menos "a" en la derecha,
pondremos unos paréntesis alrededor de ellas,
entonces vamos a multiplicar en
ambos lados por "x" menos "a".
El objetivo de eso es tener a "x" menos "a"
dividido entre "x" menos "a",
lo que solo va a ser igual a 1.
Y en el lado derecho de la ecuación, solo
tenemos "m" por "x" menos "a",
así que todo esto se simplifica a "y" menos "b"... "y"
menos "b" que es igual a...
es igual a "m" por "x" menos "a".
Y justo aquí está la forma que los matemáticos
han denominado como forma punto pendiente.
Así que esta de aquí es la forma punto pendiente...
punto pendiente...
de la ecuación que describe esta línea.
Ahora, ¿por qué es llamada forma punto pendiente?
Bueno, es muy fácil ver esto y decir, esta
es la pendiente de la línea... en verde...
ésta es la pendiente de la línea y puedo
poner los dos puntos adentro.
El punto "a", "b" está en esta línea y la
pendiente por "x" menos "a" es igual a "y","b".
Veamos porque es esto útil y porque le gusta
a la gente utilizar este tipo de cosas.
Ya no hay que usar este "a", "b"
y la pendiente de "m" más.
Hagamos esto un poco más concreto, digamos
que tenemos, digamos que alguien te dijo que
está trabajando con una línea en la que
la pendiente es igual a 2
y va a través del punto... mmm....
y va a través del punto... no sé...
digamos que va a través del punto -7,.... -7, 5.
Entonces, de una manera rápida, puedes utilizar
esta información
y tu conocimiento en la forma punto pendiente para escribir esto en esta forma.
Podrías solo decir, bueno una ecuación que
contenga este punto y que tenga esta pendiente,
sería... "y"... menos "b", que es 5... "y"
menos la componente en "y" de este punto contenido
por esta línea... es igual... es igual a
mi pendiente... es igual a mi pendiente por...
por la "x" menos la componente en "x" que
contiene esta línea, así que "x" menos -7.
Y solo como eso, hemos escrito una ecuación
que tiene una pendiente de 2
y que contiene este punto de aquí.
Y si no nos gusta esta "x" menos -7, de aquí
podemos reescribir eso como "x" más 7,
pero esta es la forma más cercana
a la forma punto pendiente.
Si quieres simplificar esto un poco, puedes
escribir "y" menos 5 es igual a 2 por "x" más 7.
Puedes ver esto como una manera de expresar
la ecuación de esta línea,
hay muchas más y con la que estamos más familiarizados es la forma pendiente ordenada al origen.
Esto puede convertirse fácilmente a la forma
pendiente ordenada al origen, para hacer eso,
nosotros solo debemos distribuir este 2, entonces
tenemos, "y" menos 5 es igual a 2 por "x"
más 2 por 7 que es igual a 14, y luego podemos
quitar este 5 a la izquierda
al sumar 5 en ambos lados de la ecuación y luego nos queda en el lado izquierdo de la ecuación, "y"...
y en el lado derecho de la ecuación...
"2x" más 19.
Por lo que esto de aquí está en la forma
de pendiente ordenada al origen.
Tienes aquí tu pendiente y tu ordenada al
origen, entonces ésta es la forma de...
pendiente...
ordenada...
al origen...
Y ésta de aquí, es la forma punto pendiente.